let's think about another scenario that
we can modeled with differential
equations this is a scenario where we
take an object that is hotter or cooler
than the ambient room temperature and we
want to model how fast it cools or heats
up and the way that we'll think about it
is the way that newton thought about it
and it is
newton's described as newton's law of
cooling
newton's law of cooling
and in a lot of ways it's common sense
it states that the rate of change of
temperature should be proportional to
the difference between the temperature
of the object and the ambient
temperature so let me write that in
mathematical terms so newton's law of
cooling tells us that the rate of change
of temperature i'll use that with a
capital t with respect to time
lowercase t
should be proportional to the difference
between the temperature of the object
and the ambient temperature so that is a
mathematical description of it and once
again it's common sense if something is
much much much much hotter than the
ambient temperature the rate of change
should be pretty steep it should be
declining in temperature quickly if
something is much much much cooler it
should be decline it should be
increasing in temperature quickly and if
something is close well maybe the rate
if the if these two things are pretty
close well maybe this rate of change
shouldn't be so big
now i know one thing that you're
thinking is like okay if if the if the
temperature is hotter than the ambient
temperature then i should be cooling my
temperature should be decreasing and a
decreasing temperature would imply a
negative instantaneous change
so shouldn't this how will this be a
negative value in the case where our
temperature of our object is greater
than our ambient temperature and the way
that that would happen is you would have
to have a negative k now if you don't
like thinking in terms of a negative k
you could just put a negative right over
here and now you would have a positive k
now it makes sense if our thing is
hotter if it has a higher temperature
than the ambient temperature so this is
a positive then our rate of change will
be negative we'll be getting cooler if
it was the other way around if our
temperature of our object is cooler than
our ambient temperature then this thing
is going to be a negative but then the
negative of that is going to be a
positive we're assuming a positive k and
our temperature will be increasing so
hopefully this makes some intuitive
sense and our constant k could depend on
the specific heat of the object how much
surface area is exposed to it or
whatever else but now given this let's
see if we can solve this differential
equation for a general solution and i
encourage you to pause this video and do
that and i will give you a clue this is
a separable differential equation
so i assume you've had a go at it so
let's now work through it together
so
we just have to algebra algebraically
manipulate this so all my t's and dts
are on one side or i should say so all
my capital t's and d capital t's are on
one side and this is going to be a
little bit more confusing because i have
a capital t and a lowercase t capital t
for temperature lowercase t for time but
hopefully we'll be able to work through
it and then i'm going to have all my my
time differentials and time variables on
the other side
so one thing i could do is i could
divide both sides by capital t minus
ambient temperature minus t sub a
remember this is just going to be a
constant based on what our ambient
temperature is we're going to assume our
ambient temperature doesn't change as a
function of time that there's just it's
just such a big room that our cup of tea
is not going to actually warm up the
room so that's just one of these
assumptions that we're going to make so
if we do that if we divide both sides by
this we are going to have so i'm going
to divide both sides let me do some new
color
if i divide both sides by that i get 1
over
capital t
minus t sub a
and let me multiply both sides times the
time differential so i'm going to have
so that
dt
d
t
so our our temperature differential
times our different temperature
differential
is going to be equal to
negative k
times our time
times our time differential so once
again to separate the variables all i
did is divide both sides by this and
multiply both sides by that
now i can integrate both sides we've
seen this show before
so
i can integrate both sides and the
integral of this is going to be
the natural log of the absolute value of
what we have in the denominator you
could do u substitution if you want if
we said u is equal to capital t minus t
sub a then d u is just going to be one
dt and so this is essentially the you
could say the integral of one over udu
and this would be the natural log of the
absolute value of u and this right over
here is u
so this is the natural log
of the absolute value of capital t
minus t sub a
is equal to once again i could put a
constant here but i'm going to end up
with a constant on the right hand side
too so i'm just going to merge them into
the constant on the right hand side so
that is going to be equal to
now here this is going to be
negative
k
t
and once again we have plus
c
and now we can take we can raise e to
both of these powers or another way of
interpreting this is that e to this
thing is going to be the same as that
so
we can write this as
the absolute value let me do that in
that same blue color
we can write this as the absolute value
of t minus t sub a
is equal to
e something about e i always think of
the color green
e
to the negative
k t
plus c
this of course is the same thing as
as
this is equal to e to the negative kt
we've done this multiple times before
negative kt
times e to the c
times
e let me do that in that same
so times
e to the c power
and we could just call this well we
could just call this another arbitrary
constant let's see if we call this c1
c1 then we could just call this whole
thing c so this we could say is c
e c
e
to the negative kt
negative kt so at least it's starting to
resemble what we did when we were
modeling population but we see it's a
little bit different instead of just
temperature on this left-hand side we
have temperature minus our ambient
temperature and so we can do a couple of
things if in a world in a world say
where we're dealing with a hot cup of
tea something that's hotter than the
ambient temperature so we could imagine
a world
where
is let's say greater than or equal to
our ambient temperature so that means
this is hot
or it's hotter i guess we could say so
if we're dealing with something hotter
than the ambient temperature then this
absolute value is going to be positive
or or the thing inside the absolute
value is going to be positive so we
don't need the absolute value or the
absolute value of it's going to be the
same thing as it and then we could just
add ta to both sides t sub a to both
sides and then we would have our
temperature
and i could even write this as a
function of time is going to be equal to
this business is going to be equal to
c
e
let me do that in the same color
c
e
to the negative kt
negative
kt
plus t sub a
plus
t sub a all i did is i'm assuming that
this inside the absolute value is going
to be positive so you
the absolute value is not going to
change the value and i added t sub a to
both sides to get this so this right
over here is going to be our general
solution in the case
in the case where we start with
something that is hotter than the
ambient room temperature and if we want
to look at the case where something is
cooler than the ambient room temperature
so that's the situation let's say t is
less than our ambient room temperature
then the absolute value of t then this
thing over here is going to be negative
and so the absolute value of is going to
be the negative of that so then this up
here results in
t sub a minus t that's going to be the
same thing as the absolute value it's
going to be the negative of the negative
so then that is going to be equal to
that is going to be equal to e
e
to the
negative k
let me do that actually i'll do the same
color i think you get the point negative
kt
plus actually let me just do
it t sub a minus t is going to be equal
to c
e
to the negative kt
so this is equal to that i'm just
assuming that t is less than t sub a and
so then to solve for t
to solve for t you could add t to both
sides and subtract this from both sides
you would have capital t
as a function of t is going to be equal
to let's see if this went on to that
side and this goes over here you would
just have the you would have t sub a
minus
minus c
e
to the negative kt did i do that right
so yep that looks right so this is the
situation
where
you're you'll have something that is
cooler
cooler than the ambient temperature
so this right over here based on the
logic of newton's law of cooling are the
two r2 or i guess these are the general
solutions to that differential equation
now the next video we can actually apply
it to model how quickly something might
cool or heat up